all right so we're going to talk about
uh
i'm going to talk about i always talk
about the ups and downs of being a
gangster mark
i'm going to give you some downsides on
it you know what i mean um
sometimes that i straight lost it came
out on we'll say the
short end of the stick you know yo
people always get up and talk about you
know the things they did and you know
i get up and talk about all the times i
have won but
there's a lot of times that i have lost
you know i've lost money
i lost drugs i've lost weapons
women you know me my wife my kids you
know
everything you know being a gang member
you know there's so many things that
come with it you know i mean uh
you go to jail and your girl leaves you
and then guys sit there and they whine
over it i mean
that's part of being a gangster you know
that's that comes with just the
territory you know i mean
you know what you're doing you're bound
to go to jail and you know you're late
she might wait she might not you know i
mean i've had everything happen to me
you know
when i was younger i used to want to
you know sell a lot of drugs you know
what i mean i want to be a big-time drug
dealer you see you guys sell and i want
to be just like him
so i saved up my money and i had about
maybe about
six seven hundred dollars and uh i went
to my older homies and
you know they they told me yeah we'll
get it for you don't trip you know so
they took me around all day but drove me
everywhere
and i'm waiting for them to get my [ __ ]
and they never get my [ __ ] you know what
i mean i'm wondering why
why why are they doing this to me or not
so uh
i see them we're sitting at the park and
i'm asking him hey man you know where's
my dope man where's my [ __ ] you know i
gave you the money
and they're older so they're telling me
not we ain't giving you [ __ ]
well at that time my little brother
comes from behind and and whacks
the guy in the back with a stick and i
swore about
10 to 15 balloons fly out of his mouth
you know so when they hit the ground we
pick them up you know what i mean and i
put them in my pocket and you know i was
pretty young at that time so i didn't
know what was even inside the balloon i
was
i knew more or less where it came from
what it was about but i didn't know
exactly what it was
so i went to one of my older uncles and
i'm like look the older homies
burned me took my money but i got this
from them you know and i thought yeah i
came up you know man
we opened one up and it was brown sugar
you know me and regular brown sugar so
i got all the way done all the way
around you know i mean and that when i
was younger you know my older homies
you know were younger so used to take
advantage of us you know i mean they
used to
want us to sell you know some weed for
them and you know
pay us like 20 25 a day you know what i
mean we're making like 500 600
for them you know they used to work us
because we were younger you know what i
mean and
you know as i was growing up you know i
could remember some occasions where
you know uh i went one time to a party
you know i mean
and we went in there and we were maybe
about there was about nine of us you
know me so i figured it we're pretty
deep you know
and we went in there you know and we
were looking around and we didn't see
anybody you know
anybody was dressed in the same attire
you know so
we kind of relaxed you know a few of us
left the other ones we stayed about four
of us stayed
and all of a sudden i started noticing
that all these dudes at the party
were grouping up and staring and i was
like
man you know these guys are regular
casual dudes you know they got the
pop doors and [ __ ] you know me thai
pants you know that's their
their era you know so i'm you know i'm
wondering what's going on and they're
grouping up they're grouping up
all of a sudden one of them comes up and
he straight disrespects our neighborhood
and says his neighbor and i look at dude
i'm like
whoa you know i mean where the [ __ ] did
you come from you know i mean
he doesn't have baggy pants he doesn't
even have a hair net
he has nothing here everything his
attire is just so
uh uh uh to up to date but you know he's
wearing tight pants and a tight shirt
and
he doesn't look like a gang member you
know i mean so
once he says that i mean it must have
been the whole party must have rushed us
you know and
when they rushed it there was so many of
them that all i remember is
just getting i'm on the ground and
they're kicking me they're kicking me
you know and
one of the older homies grabs me picks
me up to run and there's too many of
them they drop me again
they get us and they throw us over this
fence you know there's this there's this
fence and on the other side of the fence
it's nothing but
thorn bushes thorn bushes and some
cactus bushes you know with this old man
had like a guard in his backyard
these dudes threw us over inside
the thorn bushes two of us two two of my
homies landed inside the cactus bush
you know and i mean it took us forever
to get out those cactus
uh needles you know i mean they had them
all over their skin you know what i mean
i had thorns that got cut from the from
the from the uh
the guy on top of his wall he had put
pieces of glass he put him inside the
top of the wall you know so if you
jump his wall you know you're going to
stab your hands well they threw us over
so a lot of us got cut
from the glass that was on the top of
the wall you know what i mean and
before they threw us over i could
remember you know these dudes whispering
you know and telling each other you know
let's just take them for a ride you know
let's take them over here let's take
them over there and
we're getting stumped out you know i'm
about maybe about 14 years old
the guys that are beating on me they got
to be about age 17 18 because
they're already meaning they got
mustaches they're driving their cars and
everything you know and
why i'm saying you know part of being
against you is there's a downside
because
those guys knew who we were right off
the top they knew
who [ __ ] they were looking at they knew
what they were gonna do and we were so
unaware
that these dudes were there you know i
mean because they just became part of
the party you know i mean we looked at
them like everybody else like there no
one
and there must have been 30 of them
there you know and they whipped our ass
they were
every one of us they whipped everyone on
our ass except two of my homies because
you know they they they supposedly went
to go get a bat or something but they
left
we got left there and they you know they
smashed us you know right after we had
got smashed that weekend
we had went to we had went to a uh we
wanted to go to carnival
in another hood and we were gonna go
there was about maybe
ooh at least 25 to 30 of us younger
older
we were walking over there working as we
were gonna go smash these guys
and as we're walking over there i had
forgot the the
the pipe that i had brought you know my
i forgot it
when i had to use the bathroom real
quick i set it down and i didn't pick it
up when i left
so i'm heading back to go get my you
know my stick that i had what i was
carrying
and as soon as i picked up my stick i
turned to the side
and i see these two dudes coming out of
an alley
now me my homies there's like 25 of us
so there's a lot of us there so i'm
thinking right at the top
oh these are my homies you know what i
mean so i'm already like
jogging towards them and as i'm jogging
towards them
i'm looking at i'm looking i'm trying to
recognize him and i'm not recognizing
him as any of my homies that went with
me
but at that moment this little dude man
he pulled this big ass gun out of his
pants i remember i was running towards
him
and we pulled it out i just seen the
chrome you know what i mean
my heart dropped i said oh [ __ ] i was
already running toward him
so i turned i stopped turned around and
i remember
i remember hearing this thing behind me
you know
i found out what kind of gun it was you
know through people find out
he was shooting a 40 a 45
and i mean this thing was so loud that
every time you shot it
i swear i could see the flash of the
muzzle
and hear the bullets just zinging by me
i mean
cutting winds you know a few of them hit
the ground
a few more cutting went and then i seen
a couple of my homies fall and i thought
he had hit him but
i guess my homies they just got they
were ducking down but
this young guy man he let out that thing
and he shot every bullet at us you know
and
again part of being a gangster i go up
there with my homies
and i'm thinking that these guys coming
at this alley are my homies
and little do i know that they're my
enemies and they're coming to get
us you know so they caught me by
surprise you know what i mean
and that occasion right there i mean i
must have been 20 feet away from the
guys you know what i mean and
i ran in zigzags you don't mean all that
good [ __ ] and
i just you know it i'm trying to explain
the feeling of
hearing bullets as they zip by you you
know what i mean
sometimes i see war movies and i i hear
the bullets in there you know
zipping by the guys and i remember that
feeling because you know i've
come across that feeling so many times
you know where i've been cut
slipping you know i'm thinking that
everything is cool and
you know me these dudes are making a
plot to get me you know what i mean
i went to another party up there and uh
it was up there in a
you know ie somewhere and we went up
there and i didn't know that my homies
had moved up there and they got in the
[ __ ] with these dudes
but they were having shootouts and all
this [ __ ] i don't know this i go with
another
party over there you know and we get
there and
these dudes are deep and these guys are
deep they're from fontana you know
and they're deep man and i got my cr
hat on you know what i mean and you know
they already asked where i was from and
i told them you know what i mean
i noticed that they started tripping on
me you know i was wondering why why are
they tripping on me we're all the way
over there
in the inland empire michael's in los
angeles why are these guys tripping you
know
well my homegirl didn't say [ __ ] until
midway through the [ __ ]
then she tells me oh wow homie's been
getting shootouts with them you know i
mean i'm like what
you didn't tell me [ __ ] look at these
dudes now these foods
these foods had already barricaded the
door they had already blocked the door
to leave the side gate was blocked the
door in the house was blocked
they blocked all exits you know what i
mean and i was thinking man
what am i going to do you know what am i
going to do i didn't have a chance to
say anything because
as soon as i was trying to figure out
what to do bottles just started coming
bottles were just flying one hit my
homegirl right in the head
smacked her right in the head and split
her open another one hit my ankle he hit
my knee
hit my side they must they were throwing
you know full bottles of beer
you know i mean they were throwing that
at us and we weren't that far we're
maybe like
15 to 20 feet you know and again you
know
i i'm dressed in the attire you know
what i mean i'm out there
low riding being a troll or gangbanging
but
i really didn't understand that what i
was was like a poster
you know i was like a a a bulletin board
you know i was putting myself there as a
target
you know i mean um other guys were a
little smarter you know i mean my homies
used to wear
pink slingshots and bermuda shorts you
know and catch dudes slipping you know
what i mean and i used to see my homie
and i used to laugh and i'm like
look at this dude you know but he never
went to jail
he never got caught he never got sweated
by the police
but me being all gangstered up or in
size 50
when i only were like at 36 you know i
mean
50s with you know a big old sweater a
hairnet and all you don't mean a beanie
all shouldered out you know i was
getting caught
slipping because you know i dressed the
attire that my uncles had
you know i mean i wanted to follow in
their footsteps and every day
for i could say maybe eight years
i dressed nothing but a gang member you
know january everything i could a
bandanna jerseys
and that went on for eight years and
there were so many occasions where
i went somewhere and i didn't recognize
these guys but they recognized me
just from what i was wearing they knew
who i was you know they had they
they had asked who i was and i didn't
ask they were because
they didn't have the attire on you know
i mean they they were dressed
in a different fashion well you know
that those are
those are these guys now you got these
other guys on the other side
that you know they don't actually they
ain't actually from a neighborhood
but they got [ __ ] with your neighborhood
him and maybe six of his boys got jumped
by my homies
and now i'm over here at a pool party
and i'm kicking back with some women
and these dudes are giving me looks and
i don't know these guys i don't see no
tattoos on them i don't see nothing
but little by little my home really
starts whispering to me about
these dudes getting this [ __ ] with my
homies so now i know i'm asked out
well all i could do was i went in the
bathroom
and they're pounding on the door and
there's a little ass window i mean the
battle window is so small
that i don't think i could get out it i
don't think i can get out of it it's too
small
but i said man i'm not going to go back
out that door with these dudes and there
there's too many of them
you know they want to [ __ ] me up they're
liable to kill me
you know so i got to get out this window
so i tried to get out the window and my
sweater didn't want to get through
it was too big i had a big sweater and
it [ __ ] didn't want to get through
so i took my sweater off you know i mean
throughout the window
now i'm squeezing through and then my
[ __ ] pants get stuck
and wear my [ __ ] belt because i used
to pull in another first buckle but the
second buckle back i used to pull it in
so
the crease was right here it was getting
stuck on the on the lock of the window
well by this time they're already the
wood's already chipping from them
kicking in the door
it's a nice door nice bathroom door you
know i had already put the cabinet
against it you know i mean
a trash can you know i set some [ __ ] up
against it it's so big i can get time to
get out this window
well i'm about out this window and
i saw a [ __ ] grab my pant leg
now when he grabbed my pant leg
i fell out the window but he didn't let
go on my pant leg
so now i'm hanging upside down i'm
calling from my homegirl
she done rant left me now now i'm
hanging out the back of this window this
dude got me by the pants
and i can't do [ __ ] i can't get try to
grab his hand i can't do nothing
but i feel his grip loosening his grip
loosening loose anymore
so i'm trying to wiggle away from him
and i can hear him inside there
i could hear him running around through
the living rooms and
trying to come out the front door so
they could get me on the side of the
house
well what happened was he finally let go
i hit the ground i got up and what i did
was
there was a bush a big green bush just
a big big green bush maybe about six
feet wide maybe about
11 feet tall it was just a big ass bush
looked like a christmas tree but round
well all i did was i stepped right
inside it what i did was i went all the
way inside it to the middle where the
trunks and i got all the way inside that
bush
and i swear these dudes were walking
like i could see their faces
you know because i'm holding my breath
only warm hear me breathe you know i'm
inside this bush and
right in the middle of the tree and
they're just walking by you know
i i don't know what made me go inside
that bush i guess it was out of
i wanted to hide so bad because there
was nowhere to hide and
that was the best place to hide after
that i hid there
all kinds of times if i found a big tree
man i seen it i'm high there one day i'm
running i'm gonna go inside there you
know
you know that i i learned to hide in
bushes and trees to get away from people
behind these dudes catching me in a
bathroom me jumping out of bathroom
window
and i gotta jump in the bush you know
and sometimes when you jump in that bush
it's not
clean inside there you know it's real
dirty in there it gots that
dew i mean cobwebs lin you know i mean
got all kinds of [ __ ] bugs
you know you come out of that [ __ ] dirty
as hell you know but yet
it saved my life but on another hand
me being a gang member wanting to wear
the big clothes wanted to
you know not play the part but be the
part
it caused a lot of attention not only
attention from individuals
but also attention from the law you know
the law
they would see me and they they would
pull me over every chance they got and
because my homie
knocked out two normal sheriffs we used
to have the sheriff's come
and put us on the hood and then they
would give us what you used to call a
pineapple you know
he put his hands like this and it hit us
right
between the legs and sent us on top of
the hood you know he was doing that for
like about
oh [ __ ] he must have been doing that for
about a good five months
he was doing that to us he would
pineapple us and hit us between the legs
and knocked him
on the car and then my homies that used
he would get their syringe and he would
poke their arms
you know with the syringe you just poke
them a lot and you know
that was just because we were standing
on the corner or addressed the attire
you know because everybody else wasn't
getting pulled over you know these dudes
would
these cops would recognize us from a
block away because like i said at that
time i didn't figure that
i was bullish and bored i was assigned
saying look at me look at me come and
get me you know shoot me whatever you're
gonna do
you know i was i was
portraying a role that
was embedded in me it was bread into me
i i didn't choose
i guess i didn't choose i i more or less
got led into
being a gang member it wasn't my choice
i didn't grow up and say okay well i can
either be a gang member
or i could stay in school would be no it
wasn't like that
once i had 12 13 years old it was one
steady road and
that was the road that they pushed my
family and my
cousins and my uncles and they pushed
that so you know i didn't get the
opportunity to
be maybe who i wanted to be i already
knew
by the age of 13 that this is what i was
going to do this is where i was going to
go
you know prison and everything and and
that was going to happen
it was inevitable it was all going to
take place i was going to go to prison
for a long time
you know me and that's exactly what
happened you know what i mean and
you know i wish now today that i knew
the things
that i don't i wish i would have known
them then because then i would have been
a lot a lot more
clever you know a lot more smarter you
mean and not so
flamboyant with it you know me
flamboyant with it you know i'm talking
about you know
i used to be the type of individual that
you know i wouldn't disrespect you in
front of your mother
or your wife or you know your kids you
know i wouldn't disrespect
you in front of them but there was a lot
of individuals that did
you know i mean and i hated that you
know i really hated that because the
fact that
you know someone with their mother or
their old lady you know i feel that they
get a chance you know you
let them walk by you know they got a
freebie some guys wouldn't allow that
some guys wouldn't go for that with your
mother with your ladies they're gonna
try to shoot you
and put you in the ground they just
don't care you know what i mean but yet
what was i doing i was out there all
dressed gangbanger down putting
a sign up shoot me you know what i mean
and you know it
it today you know i mean i even put on
pants that are a little bit snug
and i feel that they're too tight even
if they're not
too tight they're my size i still feel
like
they're tight you know what i mean i try
to give up you know the
big shirts or the ones with l.a on them
you know
the the attire that has been so hard for
me to give up
little by little i'm cutting it out my
life you know but
being that i was a gang member a trollo
it's
embedded in my head that when i hit a
star
there's one section i'm going to look at
that's the section with the long socks
the black shirts the levites you know
i'm not going looking at
uh shorts with flowers on them you know
hawaiian shorts or hawaiian shirts you
know
i don't think i've ever owned a hawaiian
shirt or hawaiian shorts you know
i've never owned nothing like that i've
never known a suit you know i've wore a
suit but i've never owned one myself
you know i never had a suit or a coat to
wear out to somewhere nice you know what
i mean i always had
either buy it or borrow it you know
because i couldn't wear the clothes that
i usually wear to someone's wedding
i mean come on that's way out of place
you know what i mean
so you know i i i share these things
because
everybody talks about the good side of
being a gang member you know good side
of being a gangster of being a drug
dealer
but they never hit the points about the
bad things
they never show people that there's also
a bad side to this
there's also a side that no one sees and
no one talks about
because it's forbidden you know what i
mean but yet
you know i bring it out today and i talk
about things that happened in my life
because
i was so naive to the fact that
i put a sign on my back you know what i
mean
24 7. you know what i mean i actually
wonder how these [ __ ] know
where i was at
how did they know who i was you know me
why did they shoot at me
i should have known exactly why i was
dressed like
a gang member i was standing in front of
a known gang member's house
you know what i mean and i was throwing
up gang signs so
you know as i got older i came to
realize that
there's a very bad side of being a
gangster
and there's a good side and you hear a
lot of people talk about the good side
but various you talk about the bad
things
they don't want to tell you that they
came to downtown and they gave somebody
60
and they gave them six balloons and one
of them was only real
the other five were fake and the brother
burning was this little
you know what i mean she's just a little
rally and she straight burn
you know they won't tell you that but i
will i tell you i came to downtown i got
burned by the smallest brother you think
and i gave her my money like it was
nothing and i knew better
and she came back and gave me my [ __ ]
there was only one that was real all the
rest were fake
and i was [ __ ] pissed i was upset but
she got me you know she got me she
played the game she was wiser
quicker and she took my money you know
what i mean uh
another thing that happened to me was i
had my web and i loved my web and i had
my album wherever i went i slept with it
it went everywhere i went and i went to
this girl's house and started being with
her and
i [ __ ] up she told me oh man this
guy's sweating me he's coming over
stalking me i need some people
so me like a dummy i go and grab my
weapon and bring her to her house
thinking that everything's okay
that was the wrong [ __ ] thing to do
you know what i mean but
me being i want to be captain saba ho no
disrespect to any women but
i want to be captain sabo ho and save
this broad from her problems
by bringing my heat over there and
little do i know
she has a [ __ ] she's [ __ ]
with on the side waiting for him to come
to get my [ __ ]
so i leave i come back go to the spot
where i have my [ __ ] and it's gone
she told the other dude where was that
now i can't get at this guy and telling
me give me my [ __ ]
he asked my [ __ ] he he's able to shoot
me if i ask for my [ __ ]
so now i'm stuck in a predicament what
because i was walking down the street
this [ __ ] seeing me
called me because i was dressing
everything hit me up while i was from
everything that she explained her
problems
and me being a naive idiot when it got
my weapon blocked
she gave it to the other dude told him
it was that he got it
burned me for a thousand dollar weapon
and it was gone
you know and i'll be the first one to
say right i shaded the tear it hurt bad
i didn't want to lose that thing and
when i lost it i shed it to tear because
it meant so much to me it was like a
part of me and when i lost it
i felt naked i felt like i was half
there you know me
and why because i listened to a woman
that played me all the way through you
know all that she was scaring him that
was just an
act she was giving me that way she could
get my weapon and give it to
her man whoever he was you know and i
never seen this dude again you know i i
wanted to
i hope and pray that i see him again but
i never seen him again but he got me
from my weapon
and you know that was because again
my attire she recognized me because the
way i wore my clothes and
you know i go i'm gonna close so much
because
you know even the raiders jerseys the
raiders sweaters
they even labeled them as getting a tire
you know and that's a team that's the
nfl team but it was getting a tire you
know
we couldn't even wear that to school you
know we could wear nothing raiders to
school nothing black
nothing no colors gang member colors now
i don't know
gay marriage colors all i know is
they're black silver you know
what what do you mean you know i mean we
couldn't wear certain things to school
and it was like why they're sporting
but we couldn't learn because the media
and
society labeled that as gang attire so
we were not allowed to wear it
to the probation office to school you
know i mean so
things had to change we had to make
changes and i started wearing white
t-shirts
and [ __ ] like that but still it didn't
matter you know i thought
if i changed my entire little they won't
recognize me [ __ ]
because if they didn't recognize me by
my clothes they recognize me by the way
i walk
you know for some reason people say i
walk a certain way i'm not
too keen on how i walk but people have
recognized me
how i walk and they knew it was me and
it's like [ __ ] you recognize me for my
walk i must walk different than a lot of
people
but i used to get caught sleeping behind
that too you know what my [ __ ] tell
me later on the years
all i knew was you because i seen you
walking down the street and i was like
you see me walking down the street
why don't you give me that it was
because i seen you from the distance but
i recognized your walk and i was like
what the [ __ ] he recognized me walking
he came shot at me
you know me because he recognized it was
me wow you know i mean
there's so many things that you know we
don't look at
you know i mean we thought back in our
head would look cool
bacon in our head just put a sign on our
back for the cops
he's a gang member he's bald head go get
him
you know what i mean i i grew up with
long hair combing my hair back with a
pom pom
and airing it after i went into shaving
my head but
i didn't really care for shaving my head
so you know but when that came
in everybody's shaving their head and
there we go again
putting a bulletin board on her back you
know that sign
saying come and get me look at me look
who i am you know so
you know i wanted to share a little bit
today about that
there's the good and bad of being a g
and
you people know that are gangsters man
that i come up here and talk about the
real [ __ ]
there is a bad sight and a good side to
everything you know
maybe when you guys get up here you can
share some as well
some bad things that happen because
people read it all the time and they
hear
a lot of good [ __ ] about everybody
coming out on top
don't forget to tell them about when you
came out on the bottom because
they also want to hear about that you
know you get tired of hearing the same
[ __ ] this dude just gets and he gets it
he never loses yeah [ __ ] loses
but what i've learned is as long as my
losses
overcome as long as my my
victories overcome my losses then i'm
doing all right
if i got more losses than victory i'm
doing bad you know what i mean but
i think i got more victories so you know
i want to share that today with you mark
you know what i mean
tell me about the scar on your face oh
you have a scar going from your eye down
your cheek i was scaring my face
and that was done by one of my best
friends today is my best friend
you know um i'm a strong believer in you
get disciplined
on the level you carry yourself on so
when i [ __ ] up
there's no checking verbal checking
there's no verbal tongue lashing
there's no ass whooping you're nothing
or kicking on the ground
no my thing is i get stabbed
shot you know i got to get punished
severely
because i'm going to punish severely
whatever level you're on and i have to
punish you i'm going to punish you on
the level you carry yourself
on i'm not gonna put you anywhere else
just on the level you carry yourself
on and my homie he jumped the gun kind
of with this
and at the same time he took in somebody
else's information and just took it in
but then again you know today he's my
best friend because
i can sit here and honestly say that i
don't hate him i don't want nothing
against him
because the fact that he corrected me
when i was wrong
it could have been worse you know but
today i see him
and you know i had my chance to talk to
the man and you know
i let him know you know you touch me
again you are no more you know but
at the same time he did it to discipline
me
and i was wrong i was wrong i
understand where i was wrong i seen
where i was wrong and i accepted it
like a man even though it's on my face
women love scars man they dig them you
know
it's just another story to tell you know
people think man
how come you didn't end this guy you
know me because the fact that
he did what most [ __ ] won't do
you know what i mean he stepped to the
plate and took care of his business and
most [ __ ] won't do that
they won't correct me they let me hit a
wall instead of correcting me right
there on the spot
and my correction has to be severe
they're gonna let me hit that wall
where correction is no longer
uh valid it's no longer a choice you
know you're beyond correction
now you have to be ejected you know and
i'd rather be corrected than ejected you
know what i mean
i'd rather be handled than to be stuck
in question
because to be in question is very
uncomfortable to just sit there and not
know
if you're asked out or you're okay to
sit there and not know it and you can't
go anywhere but they're just
waiting on the word to come back on you
it's [ __ ] up you know so
again this on my face uh my best friend
today
he put this on my face and i don't even
see it anymore just like my teardrop
i don't see it when i look in the mirror
i don't see the teardrop i don't see the
scar i don't see nothing i just
see my face i don't i don't see it it's
not there
but a lot of people ask about it and um
my life is an open book you know me so i
i i can share it with anybody you know
i've been asked about my teardrop
all so many times but the best one i
ever i ever gave was
a ceo in prison she was sexy as how she
called me to a podium she says
excuse me um ramirez is it i said yeah
she said
i want to ask you a question but i want
you to take it personal but i've been
wanting to ask you
and i go go ahead you know ask it she
said um
that teardrop on your face does that
mean that you're missing somebody
and i said no man i said no man
that means that somebody else is missing
somebody and she looked at me like whoa
what the hell you know but
she asked the question i gave her the
answer she had to respect it you know
what i mean she said was somebody
missing somebody i said no somebody else
was missing somebody
i wasn't missing nobody you know so i
gave her her answer and
she took it like whoa this is my oh my
god how could you
you asked me the question i'm going to
give you the answer
you know my church hasn't been on my
face since the age of 15.
there was no way i went to prison by
then you know i didn't hear by then no
no
you know it's filled in and it's dark
and everybody knows what that means
so you know i wear them both on my face
and i wear them with pride because
they're things that
i have earned both ways the good way the
bad way
we're going to say the bad one the good
way but because they're back and forth
you know
one's good one's bad and i always say
there's a good side and there's a bad
side to being a gangster
here's the good side here's the bad side
you know what i mean because the fact
that
i had to do bad to get this and i had to
do good to get this you know
but when you look at them on somebody
they're both bad things
but at the same time you know what does
that story
what does that scar hold what type of
story does it hold
you know i wasn't cut because i told
them somebody i wouldn't cut because i
said the wrong thing no i was cut
because i did something wrong
and a man chose to take into his hands
and correct me
before i went too far and was unable to
be corrected anymore
so i wear with pride man and it's cool
you know women love it
they always want to kiss it i'm not
lying i mean they do
fessy white girls they they love them
man you know they love a teardrop and
scars why
i do not know but michaels just love it
you know i mean so
i dig them man and they're cool it's
cool you know but again my best friend
did it and
that's my boy man i love him more than i
love a lot of other people so
that's where it came from mark is that
cool excellent all right
johnny thank you man yeah no problem
mark you know i got some more for you
man i got you i'm gonna do mark i'm
gonna write something down
i'm gonna write some down because like
i'd be talking this to my homie and he'd
be telling me anybody
remember this [ __ ]
he goes you don't [ __ ] remember
[ __ ] breaking that food
[Music]
you